and all these I think do raise
significant questions about how the
death penalty is being applied with each
new execution the case for capital
punishment seems to get weaker and
weaker there are three reasons to get
rid of the death penalty once and for
all I believe that the death penalty is
appropriate in certain circumstances
between 1980 and 2012 California spent
four billion dollars administering death
penalty cases while actually executing
just 13 individuals when the death
penalty is in play the legal cost per
case skyrocket to an extra 134 million
dollars per year well above the cost to
implement life without possibility of
parole there's just never going to be a
way to make it less than a huge waste of
taxpayer money I believe that the death
penalty is appropriate in certain
circumstances a 2009 study concludes
flatly the consensus among criminologist
is that the death penalty does not add
any significant deterrent effect above
that of long-term imprisonment fully 88%
of criminal justice experts responding
to the poll said the death penalty does
not act as a deterrent for murder that
helps explain why states without the
death penalty consistently have lower
murder rates than ones that do I believe
that the death penalty is appropriate in
certain circumstances the state's first
role and arguably it's only one is
protecting the lives and property of its
citizens in everything it does from
collecting taxes to seizing property for
public works to incentivizing good
behaviors and habits it should use the
least violence or coercion possible no
matter how despicable murderers can be
the state can make sure we're safe by
locking them up behind bars for the rest
of their and our lives that's not only a
cheaper answer than state sanctioned
murder it's a more moral one too for
reason TV on
you